cool
okay i have a lot to say about this one
wow i'm putting you on a timer
[Laughter]
not even john's paused the video before
we're not allowed to touch this
how dare you that was a hundred dollar
keyboard
what's going on there reject nation greg
and ashley here today we're gonna watch
from nukes top five today
real ghost caught on camera top five
scary haunted houses it's been a while
since we've done some scary videos
because i've been wanting to and because
my friend ashley here special requests
by me
she is uh in something rather scary
rather demonic rather evil
on june 20th that's right june 20th yeah
paramount plus paramount plus yep that's
the one
right there paramount plus if you guys
haven't seen the trailer for evil season
two there's a link in the description
box as you go ahead check that out check
it out guys evil season two
yep be prepared to be spooked
back trying too hard now
you got to know how to be subtle when
telling people to go
watch evil season 2 june 20th
series regular over here there's no
comic-con for her to go promote her dad
so she went to the next best thing
right here greg's home real
rejects that's right
[Applause]
it felt like something was around my
like someone's hands were around my neck
[Music]
top five ghosts caught on camera in
haunted houses
uninvited house guest what
is it is it real and what is it doing
there
alan campbell went to the home to see
for himself
joshua higgins and heather bruff claim
that their highland michigan home
is haunted they say that they have heard
unexplained footsteps up and down the
stairs
and even an angry male voice screaming
and laughing in the night
but the couple who live in the house
with their 15 month old daughter
said that the frightening occurrences
don't stop there
i mean there was even a morning that i
woke up and i had felt like something
was
around my like someone's hands were
around my neck one night heather catches
a glimpse of something
absolutely terrifying on her daughter's
nanny cam
oh that always scares me the thought of
a nanny cam
whoa did you see that yes what
it's a ghost heather immediately runs
upstairs
i freaked out i stopped what i was doing
and i ran upstairs and i grabbed my
daughter
she was horrified to find that her
daughter had several mysterious
scratches across her face
i just got chills i got
it scares us that it could do something
else
the couple plans to move out of the
house as soon as they can afford it
for now they are sleeping in the same
room baby lily
every night oh wow
well we're just going to be haunted for
a while right when i when i have like
babysat kids when they have the nanny
camera
i don't know if it's because i've seen
too many movies or what but that thought
always goes in my mind
that i might see somebody walk by so do
you think that was real i mean
i believe in this stuff so i think so i
wonder if the baby was like crying and
freaking out because i feel like
babies and dogs can always like sense
when there's ghosts there you know what
i mean i mean the fact that the baby had
scratches all over her yeah they should
have interviewed the baby
yeah the baby's point of view here were
you screaming when this goes past you
i believe it that was it looked real you
know if i believe it i'm also
gonna stay poor and move out and be like
we're living on the street or
we're living with this ghost what do you
want they should sage that room asap
yeah that's the key that's right all
right haunted places are missing
some good los angeles scenes
a tale from the crypt
now this next video is not technically a
haunted house
but maybe something a bit spookier a
haunted cemetery crypt
the poster of this video says that he
was walking through the hallway of a
mausoleum in a mexico cemetery
late in the afternoon when he happened
upon
another strange visitor near the tombs
there's howling in the background
oh god you scared me
what happened this is like a legit
horror movie scene
my nipples are so hard right now
is something gonna pop out
he doesn't sound that scared the guy
who's talking
hmm maybe it's a performance
that was nuts is it over
[Music]
so he's gonna be around the corner
now there's something else that's very
bizarre in this video that you might not
have spotted
the first time through watch as the guy
filming approaches the area where the
young boy had been standing
okay oh i got another chill maybe that's
good
did you see it no what's he talking
about
what the hell like no like it looks like
somebody said what looks like a boy
pierced from inside a sealed crypt with
no door
what the hell is he talking about i
don't really see i don't understand that
is this a ghost caught on camera in a
haunted cemetery crypt
or simply a well-edited hoax there could
have been a head to the side
in a video like this where you whip pan
away there could be a hidden cut they're
very easy to do i mean i feel like this
is so scary that it feels fake
slowing this part down yeah please do i
don't see what he's describing
i don't either yeah i don't see it
i don't understand that part oh right
here yeah but it like nah that's just
the smudge
yeah that looks like a smudge seeing
that's like an actual boy
popping up i don't know i don't know if
i think it's fake do you think it's fake
i think it's fakie i mean if not and
it's real this guy is awfully calm
i feel like we've said a lot of things
that help support the argument that it's
fake
okay it's really well done though
it's scary you scared me more than not
scared because you screamed
oh man it made my nipples harder you
know like it was really terrifying
that's where my chills go it's a weird
thing you're like ooh goosebumps yeah
and i'm like hard nips that's what
happens to me every time person who
uploaded this video claimed that every
morning he would awaken to find a
particular door in his house
open even though he had closed it tight
the night before
no no then one day while walking through
his house
he was shocked to see what could only be
described as a
face staring back at him from behind the
door's glass is that
actually friendly camera to record and
captured this
scary video oh no i'm so nervous
because he says
oh wait a minute
is this like whoa that's nuts
do you see it is this a see-through door
like it's got like a is it kind of clear
you can kind of see through it uh
that's a great question what the hell
oh my goodness chills
all here he's also calm
oh no
there's a baby crying healthy
[Music]
look oh my goodness what's that baby
i don't know i'm gonna have nightmares
tonight though
[Music]
yo that was so scary
[Music]
the video poster says that the sound of
the crying child could not
be heard when he recorded the video
[ __ ] they only heard the cries after
playing the video back
[Applause]
in the comments some have argued that
since there are doors in the small
entryway
the video could be faked by someone
simply slipping back into another room
and hiding
when the door is opened however that
person would have to be pretty fast
since the face disappears almost
instantaneously
if the video is a hoax it would be more
likely that it's done with some crafty
video effects work
i mean i feel like what what do you
think is this a ghost playing peek-a-boo
or just a hoax i feel like some of these
things are like
scarier than things that i've seen in
like horror movies that i feel like if
these things
are hoaxes like these people are pretty
good yeah you guys have a career
well seriously like i would say that is
this real or fake let's even if we say
it's fake
that is really well done exactly like
it's still
really really scary that i'm getting
more scared watching this than i do in
some horror movies yeah cause like that
guy
the thing that's really making it seems
fake to me is that
the guy seems like he's doing a very
specific choreography
yeah i mean the person could be like
hiding behind this wall when he closes
like go
up to the thing and then like go back as
soon as he's about to open it kind of
thing
maybe it could also just be a really
good visual
the right kind of editor people who do
youtube videos could easily do that i
would
say it's fake just because it seems like
he's doing very specific movements to
make sure they could do the vfx
insert of the thing right and i don't
know if i believe the baby crying
the baby cry which is too much to it's
me over the end yeah i was like
it's over the top like you were saying
it's a really well done like spooky v
it's a scary creepy video yeah just like
the last one like these things should be
in movies some people just get mad if
like fake
but i'm like to me i could still admire
a good craftsmanship of something
they're trying to sell
israel it still scares me if you didn't
have crying baby i might have fallen for
it
haunting now many people are familiar
with the infamous
enfield haunting which inspired the
movie contrary to
the enfield haunted house originally
gained notoriety not only
we were just talking about it this movie
is so good
but also because the haunting was
verified by multiple
independent sources the witnesses even
included
the local police they were even more
baffled when two of their beat
constables
reported seeing an arm chair levitate
across the hodgson's living room
it came off the floor or nearly a half
inch i should say
and i saw it slide off to the right
about three and a half to four feet
before it came to rest well there's
actually another lesser known haunting
that has even more independent
verification
than the infield haunting that's the
haunting of this small house in
portomont chile
the residents of this home said that
they heard the strange voice of a woman
screaming in the night telling them to
get
out soon after the bizarre transparent
image of a woman begin to appear
in their home videos and photographs but
the story gets even weirder
a local priest was called to the home to
bless the house
allegedly this is video footage from the
priest's visit
[Music]
allegedly
but the bizarre paranormal encounters at
the portomont house
didn't stop there late one night the
chilean police were called to the home
the family claimed that the evil spirit
in the house was quote lifting objects
and starting small fires around the
house
when the police arrived they were
shocked to find that the story was 100
percent
true what
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah that's
what appears to be something flying
across the room inside the house
okay i have a lot to say about this one
[Music]
wow i'm putting you on a timer
not even john's passed the video before
we're not allowed to touch this
how dare you that was a hundred dollar
keyboard
oh my god i 100 believe that one because
there's like cops involved
i don't know like there's something
about like the footage of it and like
the interview that just makes it feel
more like authentic and legit like the
last one where he like sets up his
camera and is doing you know what i mean
like this is like
in the moment happening and they're
talking to like officers and stuff don't
you believe it
yeah like especially the cop just being
so like
yeah this is my six paranormal activity
cases
about it yeah it's like they reported
it's part of uh it's like i feel like in
chile they have
they actually take like paranormal
activity i think so
so matter of fact about them it was it
was just like what it was
we can confirm it's a paranormal
activity yeah it has been confirmed yeah
they were throwing dishes someone threw
a knife at my
epidemic that's back in this part of
town
is so casual wow and then the one that's
the conjuring is based off of that story
i believe that one too
especially because like the officers on
that with their british accents they
sound like barry
yeah those british people can trick yeah
they sound like everyone just sounds
very like
official about it i don't know i totally
believe in both of those the conjuring
one
and this one this one i believe a little
more because of the amount of
the neighborhood that i'm going in the
cops just being like
yeah we walked in that's what was
happening they're not lying that is
crazy
wow and then yeah it's just randomly
flying wow and it didn't seem like the
camera was like their
place there to watch something fly like
it legitimately did seem like it was
caught on camera or it's just the
greatest hoax they're really like cops
that are paid off to hide for these
gangsters that live there
they should be a movie about that
[Music]
oh there's more maybe i paused it
prematurely yeah you got to learn to be
a professional
[Laughter]
the family was removed from the
residence for the night but
still lived there to this day oh they
still live there what do you think
is the puerto mont haunted house all
just an elaborate hoax
one actually perpetrated by not only the
family
but local clergy and even the police no
or is this actual proof that ghosts and
haunted houses really do exist
you decide that is what if it's fake
that is the best fake video i've ever
seen
yeah 2022 he is not a believer in the
supernatural
but after his family moved into their
new house they all began to experience
strange things one night he was watching
his two daughters on their baby monitor
and he saw this
damn baby monitors
wait is that a ghost child or a real
child on the baby monitor
that's a real child okay i was like wow
what's happening he's about to do
parkour
[Laughter]
oh what wait was the girl was the girl
on the couch the fake
the ghost i think so
no how many children are there what is
happening right now
i think that the one with the i i think
it almost the one on the couch every
image of another small
child peering over the child gate and
watching his daughters play
but when he goes so confusing
okay okay there's two real children
and one maybe watching over the two real
ones okay what is the
thanks for watching if you'd like to
suggest a video for inclusion in a top
five list
go to facebook.com and hit the send
message button
i don't that one was a little confusing
i think what they were trying to say was
there was
a ghost child peering over the baby gate
his two children but i don't know i
think that's reaching what about you i
think it was yeah i think it was nothing
yeah i think the first one baby monitor
and the house in chile
yeah the other ones are really well done
and weirdly the fifth one kind of felt
like the weakest
yeah that was number one interesting way
to put a list video together
[Laughter]
subscribe to nuke's top five man guy is
still killing it after so many years and
keeps dishing out some
such amazing videos thank you nukes top
five putting this together thank you
because now i won't sleep tonight
yeah go watch evil
it's your twentieth if you don't want to
sleep you could also
watch evil june 20 yeah we have we're
taking the right tone
into promoting evil today thank you so
much for being here this is fun
this is fun subscribe click bells hit
like buttons
[Music]
you